there's something in the country that is
really ugly and that is the reimagining
of American history as inherently evil
and really bad and that means there is a
reimagining going on of Independence Day
now on the left this has been going on
for a quite a while the idea of the
Declaration of Independence is bad why
because it lies at the root of a system
of racism sexism bigotry homophobia you
hear this sort of stuff from people like
Pharrell Williams who's done pretty well
in the United States you hear it from
columnist over at salon magazine they're
gonna hear it increasingly over time as
leftist begin to reflect the woke brand
of history led by Howard Zinn that
basically suggests that America's a bad
place and that the Declaration of
Independence is really bad and they're a
mess July 4th is not really worth
celebrating now all of that is wrong
July 4th is absolutely worth celebrating
because July 4th was the celebration of
the cementing of certain values that are
key to all prosperity all human freedom
in modern civilization Declaration of
Independence upholds certain immutable
fundamental truths upon which all of
America is built it is a hundred percent
true that those principles were not
lived in accordance with by the founding
fathers or by subsequent generations of
Americans but the whole point of
American history is that these
principles were true they were good and
they will realize for more and more
Americans over time but that is the real
story of American history so let's talk
about the real history of the
Declaration of Independence and the
principles that it actually embodies for
just a second beyond all of the woke
talk about how all systems of power in
the United States all racist and brutal
spring from the Declaration of
Independence first of all just a little
bit of kind of fun history the reality
is that the Declaration of Independence
was actually voted on and signed on July
2nd so John Adams actually thought that
July 2nd was gonna be the big day he
wrote about this he said the second day
of July 1776 will be the most memorable
a polka in the history of America I am
apt to believe that it will be
celebrated by succeeding generations as
the great anniversary festival it ought
to be commemorated as the day of
deliverance by solemn acts of devotion
to God Almighty and not to be solemnized
with pomp and parade with shows games
sports guns bells bonfires and
illuminations from one end to this
continent to the other from this time
forward forevermore
so he's only off by two days right the
reason he was off by two days is because
your live fourth was the day that
Congress authorized and printed it so
that was the day that really the
American public first got
with the Declaration of Independence so
what is in the Declaration of
Independence Abraham Lincoln rightly
suggested that the Declaration of
Independence was essentially an apple of
gold and at the Constitution which was
framed in order to make presents the
values of the Declaration was the frame
of silver so he described it that way he
said this is the Apple of gold and the
Constitution is the frame of silver
designed to sort of embody the values of
the Declaration in a governmental
structure this is what the Federalist
Papers are all about the Federalist
Papers are all about how you take the
high principles of the Declaration and
then implement them in real life and of
course all of American history is about
how those high principles are made
manifest for more and more human beings
over time let me just read you because
it's a it's it's such a beautifully
written document there's a reason that
there are statues of Thomas Jefferson
okay they're not because he was a slave
holder it is not because of his
relationship his perverse relationship
with Sally Hemings the reason that
Thomas Jefferson was president of the
United States is because he wrote these
words and these words are still some of
the most glorious words ever written
this is from the Declaration of
Independence and it is the key to
American philosophy quote we hold these
truths to be self-evident that all men
are created equal that they are endowed
by their creator with certain
unalienable rights and among these are
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness that to secure these rights
governments are instituted among men
deriving their just powers from the
consent of the governed okay that long
sentence is probably the most famous
sentence and the most important sense in
in all of American history one of the
most famous and important sentences in
all of human history our founding
fathers pledged their lives and their
duty and their sacred honor to those
principles so did the soldiers who fell
to fight slavery at Gettysburg so did
the civil rights heroes who are standing
in order to make present those promises
to fulfill the promissory note as Martin
Luther King jr. suggested that was that
was laid out in the Declaration of
Independence so what does this mean well
the philosophy of the US rests on three
basic principles first the reality of
natural rights pre-existing government
government does not create your rights
your rights pre-exists government that
means that the government is instituted
in order to protect those rights this is
point number two the government is not
there to invade your rights the
government is only in power to protect
the rights you had before government so
that means the government does not get
to dictate your rights government does
not get to encroach upon your rights
they are in fact inalienable they're
unalienable ourian alienable there's
still debate over which word is proper
adam has picked inland inalienable
Jefferson picked on
big fight at the time those two
principals the reality of natural rights
that preexist government that's a big
thing because if you're a communist you
believe all rights come from the
government the rights of property comes
from the government the right to health
care comes from the government that's
not just a communist thing that is sort
of a social left-wing thing now more
broad left-wing thing is that there are
positive rights that government provides
to you that's not what the declaration
says it says you have rights to life
liberty and property they existed in a
state of nature they pre-exists
government this comes from Lockean
philosophy the philosophy of John Locke
ok then government is instituted to
protect those rights not to invade those
rights government is there to make sure
that nobody else invades your life your
liberty or your property that is what
government exists you do at its most
fundamental level and finally the
Equality of all human beings before to
the law when the Declaration of
Independence says that all men are
created equal it does not mean that we
all have the same abilities because
obviously that's that's stupid and
untrue it doesn't mean that we are all
the same height it doesn't mean that we
all have the same qualities it means
that we are all equal before the law we
are all equal in the rights given to us
by God that predate government right
those are the three principles the
fundamental principles the Constitution
was created in order to protect these
principles it created a system of checks
and balances so they couldn't have a
majority just override individual rights
in the name of the so-called common good
the Constitution was a compromise
document because they had to be hammered
out that means there are serious flaws
in the Constitution specifically for
example the three-fifths clause but the
three-fifths Clause contrary to modern
popular opinion which is wrong was
designed to actually minimize slave
power not to maximize slave power the
slave states wanted all slaves to be
counted for purposes of congressional
apportionment but then not to be able to
vote so counting three-fifths was a
compromise designed to actually lessen
slave state power this is clear to all
constitutional historians and scholars
who've actually studied the issue have
you ever had to chase down a client or a
company that owes you money euphoria
work or maybe you're stuck in the
dinosaur age and you're still creating
invoices in Microsoft Word all of this
is a waste of time you need be on top of
your invoices and you need to do it in
style in an easy fashion this is why you
should be using links tell our friends
over at blink tale they've built an
invoicing software that helps you stay
on top of all the invoices and all the
money and keep track of everything in
one place some of the things you can do
with points help send beautiful custom
branded invoices and estimates in
seconds and stay on top of those
outstanding invoices so you don't have
to just shuffle through a sheaf of paper
on your old Microsoft Word docs you let
your customers and clients pay your
invoices online which is really
convenient and you even get instant
notifications when a customer opens your
invoice you know who exactly is dodging
up the bill last time worrying about
billing that means more time focusing on
the work more time building up your
business if you are a business owner you
should be focused on building that
business not on all of the sort of busy
work off the invoices so get it done
right now easily and quickly try bling
sale for free @ bling sale comm slash
men that is a b li NK s al e comm / ben
bling sale comm / man go check them out
today and try it out for free bling sale
comm / pun the constitutional systems
enumerated powers right we're designed
to prevent the government from
encroaching on your rights the
government only has these specific
powers the government does not have any
other powers because if you give the
government more power it has more power
to invade the rights that were
guaranteed by the declaration of
independence now one of the things that
the modern disintegration is as I call
them in my new book how to destroy
America in three easy steps one of the
things the modern disintegration is have
very much in common with the people who
were in favor of slave holding in the
Constitution is they believe the
Declaration and the Constitution were
separable the reason we celebrate July
4th and it's become much more of a
celebration day than Constitution Day is
because Constitution day is really about
the implementation of a governmental
system the declaration is about those
high those highfalutin principles
there's a line of people in American
history who didn't like those principles
so slaveholders didn't like those
principles John C Calhoun said the
Declaration of Independence was a lie he
said the Constitution was the only thing
that mattered because it was just a
bargain between the states and if that
bargain was violated then you got to
dissolve the Constitution Abraham
Lincoln argued that the Constitution was
meant to embody the principles of the
Declaration which is why the federal
government had the power to move toward
fulfilling the principles of the
Declaration of Independence even if it
meant rewriting the bargain of the
Constitution a little bit in accordance
with the declaration right that is the
main debate there Woodrow Wilson an
enemy to freedom also suggested that the
Declaration of Independence no longer
matter because the very concept of
natural rights individual natural rights
prevented the government from doing the
best work that it needed to do the
progressive movement was based on the
idea the founders were wrong there were
no immutable truths self-evident truths
there was no equality before law because
absolutely certain people should be
given
privileges we see this now in the notion
that if you are of a particular ilk then
you don't deserve good treatment at the
hands of the law Brett Kavanaugh is a
good example of this due process doesn't
apply to Brett Kavanaugh because Brad
Kavanagh is is white and male and has
benefited from the system and so anybody
who upholds the notion of equal justice
before law is actually upholding a
system that is in and of itself
evocative of hierarchies so there are
two speeches that I think are really
important when we talk about July 4th
one is from Frederick Douglass who as
I've said is the second founding father
and the second is from Calvin Coolidge
maybe the most underrated president in
American history Frederick Douglass
speaks of why July 4th didn't originally
apply to black Americans and suggest
sits shortcoming he spoke this in 1852
while slavery was still very much alive
and suffice it to say Frederick Douglass
suffered a lot more under slavery than
anybody alive today
right so Frederick Douglass in saying
this is recognizing the great principles
of July 4th and recognizing that those
principles had to be extended and in
their extension in May July 4th worth
celebrating for all Americans
he said the signers of the Declaration
of Independence were brave men they were
great men too great enough to give Fame
to a great age they believed in order
but not in the order of tyranny with
them nothing was settled that was not
right with them justice liberty and
humanity were final not slavery and
oppression are the great principles of
political freedom and of natural justice
embodied in that Declaration of
Independence extended to us that was the
question of American history the answer
of the Civil War was yes the answer of
the Civil Rights Act in 1964 and the
civil rights movement was yes it was MLK
who cited the Declaration of
Independence as the inspiration for the
civil rights movement that's why July
4th is worth celebrating and then
there's Calvin Coolidge his speech was
given on one hundred and fiftieth
anniversary of July 4th it's a beautiful
speech he talks about the the innate
value of the principles he's really
arguing with Woodrow Wilson here who
said that the Declaration of
Independence was hackneyed and the
phraseology was old Calvin Coolidge says
if all men are created equal that is
final if they are endowed with
inalienable rights that is final if
governments derive their just powers
from the consent of the governed that is
final no advance no progress can be made
beyond these propositions if anybody
wishes to deny their truth or their
soundness
the only direction in which he can
proceed historically is not forward but
backward toward the time when there was
no equality no rights of the individual
no rule of the people we live in an age
of science and of abounding
accumulation of material things these
did not create our declaration our
declaration created them in other words
all the good stuff in your life in
America that Springs from the philosophy
of the Declaration do not throw it away
do not throw away July 4th simply
because you have a more attractive
version of history that you'd like to
present it makes you more self-righteous
than you actually are July 4th is a
great celebration of fundamental
American principles those principles are
well worth celebrating for all of us
hope you have a wonderful Independence
Day and while you're at it go pick up a
copy of how to destroy America in three
easy steps which discusses all of this
at more length if you enjoyed this video
share it with a friend and make sure
that you're subscribed in the link below